[Music]
in maybe not a good idea news submitted
by kale salads no a Kids app made by
Weight Watchers is getting backlash from
parents and nutritionists we need it
yeah kirbo with the k childhood obesity
is real bro especially in america but
the argument is that it will mean people
don't like Weight Watchers right because
in general yeah they have really good
desserts though I think the new movement
is like intuitive eating
yeah age I don't feel that you should do
people are doing what they want to do
this is why people are in the situation
but so people because they're marketing
it to kids
I think that's putting people off Weight
Watchers tried to do something this is
what intuitive eating get to me I just
think that's intuitive eating though my
intuition says it's [ __ ] gold yeah I
know but now so they came out with this
to work into this could have been before
like public school systems were
incorporating Weight Watchers programs
like for free for kids which at first
one you hear it's like yeah that sounds
good to like combat childhood obesity
yeah but people came out against it
saying that it is a negative thing
because it places too much emphasis on
like counting and it promotes disorder I
don't know like I don't know what I
don't even know what that means to make
a comment the same thing when we grew up
like there's a food group right there
was a lot of the opposite taught to me
like I see this as a step forward where
before those misinformation so now let's
just give them better information and
you're not controlling them not even
better information just information
period there was nothing let's hear the
article Thank You Jo alright so Weight
Watchers I think making my decisions
before the article oh I already made up
my mind I read the headline I heard it
okay so Weight Watchers which now they
call themselves
w-w-w-w-w-w-wait Wonder Woman Walter
White
yep a lot of WWE's out there it's
[ __ ] hard to say about your table you
[Music]
www.weiu.net said I don't know where I
bought you that with you it's easier to
say it with the accent it would be
aggressive WWE can't even do it so they
came out with kirbo looks like
MyFitnessPal mm-hmm yeah and so they're
saying here that kids will have access
to like their own type of coach so
they're saying like you know we plan
your meals using the kirbo plate uh and
then this is where they like you can
track it and then this is what we'll
having a chat with their own person
co-heads they're not technically
nutritionist nutrition [ __ ] it some
Indian guy or like pediatrician these
aren't dietitians like they're not
actual they're just Joe schmo's off the
street that just got a baby I'm telling
you
yeah he's typing or it's a bot I bet you
it's like an automated response bot no
so they they're like marketing people
market
okay so ww said quote if we want to live
our purpose of making wellness
accessible to all and doing it outside
an academic Medical Center we're not
going to be able to hire pediatricians
dieticians exercise physiologists and
thank you physiologist and psychologists
what we do well is take science and
scale it measure the impact to make sure
we're living up to our purpose so
they're saying that the people like the
staff descriptions on the website is
trained X the trained experts include
people with degrees in economics tourism
management and communications what all
the people that got bachelors that
couldn't get a job that's the that's
they're trained experts do not get do
not major in these kind of jobs or else
you're gonna be [ __ ] working at WW so
the thing here
ww so like one of the questions that
they ask is think about your goals on
kirbo which one is most important to you
and one of them is to lose weight
another one is to make parents happy oh
my god what the [ __ ] kind of what so
people are just like this is not sweet
that is no something that I got a it's
not a nutritionist but it's like a
personal trainers certification for
nutrition so it's called precision
nutrition and that's a question that I
would ask if I was working with someone
one-on-one to see oh do you or are you
trying to make someone else happy is
this not really your goal like to figure
out like really why do you want to do
then you call a social worker and say I
think somebody's yet seriously you refer
out if someone has so I wonder if I
would hope that this will have some way
to refer out whenever like signs of
eating disorders are like being maybe
they have some sort of weight like
responses that are like you can't keep
going on the tap you should talk to a
professional I think anymore they can
target marketing at you so like oh we
know that they have this stigma we can
attack that [ __ ]
I think that's weird is fun cuz it's all
about their staff by marking people
right it's all profit yeah that's weird
as [ __ ] and for kids yeah it's for kids
I don't like that it's directed to kids
to sign on and control and do all that
what I would have preferred and I would
back a little bit more if they had made
it for parents to educate them how to
put together a healthy meals or snacks
or whatever so that they're you know
regurgitating the information and giving
it to their kids
I do understand I understand the kids
Ingle I'm not saying I support it but I
think I understand the kids ingo because
if kids have phones anyways and if kids
have apps anyways they're like why don't
we just put the apps in the hands of the
kids so that we can directly access them
because nowadays a lot of parents aren't
even app savvy to begin with so that
this would just go over parents heads
but no kids going to the Weight Watchers
hat I think that's our goal though
I don't I think that's the glue they
even change the name I would never ever
[ __ ] want to do that no I would not
as a kid what's your back like when I
was like like maybe fifth or sixth grade
that's when I started looking at my
buddy like oh I wish I was like you feel
fat I never felt like that but I would
definitely look at other people and be
like I wish I was as skinny as that girl
me reason why people are so like rubbed
the wrong way off of this app is because
it's targeted from kids age of 8 it says
memantine that's right [ __ ] young
kids on phones when they're eight
there's that eight-year-old kid there
kids with obesity for me I'm still like
as a kid you should just be a [ __ ]
kid you know that's your parents
responsibility like the parents are
probably back to it but this this seems
to be an app for the parents I mean no
it seems like it's for the game you know
it's for the kids to use it's like like
visually stimulating for them but the
parents found it put it on the phone the
kids not gonna find that [ __ ] on their
own they stress that the app is meant to
be a family based approach and but
they're just saying that they're just
having these kids work to lose weight
and then the fact that they're asking
like is this for somebody else to make
you happy but then what you brought up
is a good point
that they don't mention about like doing
things for other people
yeah but um but yeah definitely made at
this one how do they like how how do you
convince a kid to download this app but
I mean you gotta pay yeah this is like
for people they have like a monthly
thing so this is for parents who have
fat kids and I want to do something
about it
yeah I hmm but now there's a change.org
petition going on
they're always there as one comes to
Weight Watchers that but not for the
same reasons because i have much joy in
life when i see a fat kid and then and
then their parents follow and then
they're just as fat but it's like a
bigger version of them and then they
have a dog that's just as fat and in now
it's like a whole family that's kind of
round yeah and and i think it's really
cute and then you're at their house and
you see a skinny cat and yeah like oh
that's the stray yeah that's the
yeah because I always wanted to like see
my friend's parents at parent-teacher
like conferences and [ __ ] and I'm like
man I love this I can't wait I hope your
parents are just as bad as you - [ __ ]
awesome yeah so you know Jamila she's a
girl from a good place
a good place so she's like very vocal
and we talked about it before and she
can use where she's very vocal she's
also really fat no she I kid she's the
most beautiful actress I think I've ever
seen yes Ruby Rose yeah all chicks like
that Ruby Rose yeah Ruby Rose is hot but
by Jamila is beside her named Camila
yeah she's so hot she's really gorgeous
um okay let me show you a photo really
quick cuz I didn't prepare a photo of
her face um but she said she ended up
tweeting oh [ __ ] no are we kidding
breeding obsession with weight and
calories and food at the age of 8 I was
11 when my obsession started being put
on a diet for being the heaviest girl in
the class I became afraid of food it
ruined my teens and 20s and then she
says if you are worried about your
child's health slash lifestyle give them
plenty of nutritious food and make sure
they get plenty of fun exercise that
helps their mental health and don't
weigh them yeah don't burden them with
numbers surgery or success / failure
it's a slippery slope
cuz likely hearing your experience when
you were going into 6th 5th or 6th grade
and you were comparing yourself to where
you're like man I want to look like that
like I can already hear you going into
like like an eating disorder oh for sure
yeah yeah that's Amelia really quick oh
yeah she's so she was good she should be
some like body positivity is this like
really hot it's Ashish but she used to
be fat yes like when she was a kid or
was it enough to think her parents for
putting her on the program and this
doctor up so mentally mentally [ __ ]
her she'll ride that where she is now
because she
she was at a way stronger more mature
mindset and it would have been way have
been healthier weight like the healthier
what is healthier like a fifth-grader
but I guess I wouldn't emphasize the
weight so much right where I would be
like like you can see if someone's over
overweight I need to set a goal if you
don't set a target or something maybe it
could be like there and that you don't
like walking around the blockers yeah
you don't have to step on a scale to be
like you look healthier that's true like
we could've had a go-kart with her
favorite like Twinkie or whatever and
she just runs after it every day and at
the end you give it to her without
saying anything that's gonna make a game
out about it yeah you make a game out of
it and then she actually lost weight
without her knowing that's you happy
every day yeah and every day she gets a
Twinkie oh yeah like if Tyco starts
getting fat then I'm gonna be like oh
[ __ ] as a parent I'm filling my child
dude let's go out let's go to the park
before we go to bed or before you chase
a Twinkie
yeah that's runner on the blog do the
children with obesity usually it's more
common for them to come from like poor
families yes and families also that
aren't cooking at home yeah they're not
educated they don't know what to eat and
then you have that combined with
prepackaged like Richie ready-made food
that is very palatable too so it tastes
really good so you never know when to
stop that sounds like this app is made
for those people but those people are
not gonna go to this app yeah you don't
mean like it's so weird
well one thing that they do talk about
which I heard a lot of people were upset
with is something that I have used with
my clients and it's having them look at
foods that are like red light green
light yellow light oh yeah I didn't talk
about that's what people are really
upset about because it's like kind of
teaching people to say like okay for me
a red light food where I know if I have
it in the house are like brownies but
that turns into a green light when I
don't have it like ready-made right so I
can have brownies in the house but I
gotta like cookies yeah because it you
could control the ingredients well no
cuz then I'm too lazy to thank yous
behind before it oh and you burn
calories cooking in
food would beat for me it would be like
buying shirt at brownies from the store
but like a green light food where I can
have as much as I want
it's like salad we're like yellow light
where it's like taste really good I
enjoy it it's but I know that like I
should slow down I'm tomorrow and like
chips
I don't like keep eating them over and
over again but brownies I'll eat the
whole brownie thing if it's right there
in front oh man oh yeah welcome to the
country that doesn't know though man you
go to Cheesecake Factory and every salad
is 2,000 calories yeah something's got
to be done somewhere life support this
kind of shade persist for a full frame
okay no I want to keep America fat I
like I think it's cute against nope big
babies
[Music]
[Music]